Neutron stars.
Manhattan sized, but with a mass twice that
of our sun.
So dense.
A teaspoon of their matter weighs a billion
tons.
Mind blowing objects that arrive with a
bang.
Neutron stars spark into life amid the death
of their parent star.
They are the ultimate story of resurrection
or of life from death.
It's all part of a cosmic cycle.
Stars are born from giant clouds of very cold
gas.
Those clouds collapse under their own
gravity, and the density of the core at the
center of that collapse starts to increase.
A star is a huge nuclear fusion reactor.
The force of its gravity is so powerful that
it fuses atoms together to make progressively
heavier and heavier elements.
The star fuses hydrogen into helium once it
exhausts its hydrogen.
Then, if it's massive enough, it can start
fusing helium at its core.
Fusion continues forming carbon, oxygen,
nitrogen all the way up to iron.
Once the star has iron in the core, it's
almost like you've poisoned it, because this
extinguishes the nuclear reactions in the
core of the star.
You fuse something into iron and you get no
energy.
All of a sudden, there's nothing to support.
The crush of gravity.
No radiation pressure.
Pushing out means no pressure keeping the
outer regions from falling in.
And that's what they do.
As the star collapses in its death throes,
its core becomes the wildest, craziest, and
freakiest pressure cooker in the whole
universe.
The ingredients are all in place.
Time to start cooking up a neutron star.
If we were to scale up an atomic nucleus to
be the size of a baseball in a normal atom,
the nearest electron would be way over in
those trees.
But in the extreme conditions that lead to
the formation of a neutron star, those
electrons can be pushed closer to the
nucleus.
They can come zipping in from any direction,
and if the temperatures and pressures are
high enough, they can even strike the
nucleus and enter it and they can hit a
proton. And when they do, they become
converted into more neutrons.
So in the formation of one of these objects,
the protons and electrons disappear and
you're left with almost entirely pure
neutrons, with nothing to stop them from
cramming together and filling up this entire
baseball with neutrons, leading to incredibly
high densities.
With the sea of electrons now absorbed into
the atomic nuclei, the matter in the stars
can now press together a lot tighter.
It's like squeezing 300 million tons of mass
into a single sugar cube.
As the star collapses, enormous amounts of
gas fall towards the core.
The core is small in size, but huge in mass.
Billions of tons of gas bounce off of it,
then erupt into the biggest fireworks display
in the cosmos. A supernova.
It's massive, it's bright, it's imposing.
Supernova are among the most dramatic events
to happen in the universe.
The single star dying, one star dying can
outshine an entire galaxy.
And arising out of this cataclysm, a new and
very strange cosmic entity.
When the smoke finally clears from the
supernova explosion, you're left with one of
the most real, fascinating, unbelievable
monsters in the entire universe.
Humans have been witnessing supernovas for
thousands of years, but we're only now just
starting to understand what we've truly been
witnessing.
The births of neutron stars.
But while supernovas are big and bright,
neutron stars are small, and many don't even
give off light.
So how many neutron stars are out there?
We know of about 2000 neutron stars in our
galaxy, but there probably are many, many
more. I'm talking about tens of millions in
the Milky Way alone, and certainly billions
throughout the universe.
Neutron stars may be small, but some give
themselves away shooting beams across the
universe. Unmistakable pulsing strobes of a
cosmic lighthouse.
Our knowledge of neutron stars is expanding
fast.
But we didn't even know they existed until a
lucky discovery just over 50 years ago.
Cambridge, the Mullard Radio Observatory.
Jocelyn Bell.
Grad student operating the new radio
telescope, scanning the sky, doing all sorts
of cool astronomy stuff and sees what she
calls a bit of scruff in the data.
This scruff is a short but constantly
repeating burst of radiation originating a
thousand light years from Earth.
It's so stable and regular that Bell is
convinced there's something wrong with her
telescope.
She returns to that spot and finds a
repeating regular signal, a single point in
the sky that is flashing at us, continually
saying, hai, hai hai, blip.
Blip, blip.
Boom boom boom.
Pulse pulse pulse.
Nothing that we know of in the universe has
such a steady, perfectly spaced in time
pulse. It seems so perfect that it must have
been artificial.
It looks like someone is making that.
But it turns out it's not a person, but a
thing.
What she discovered is called a pulsar.
A pulsar is a type of rapidly spinning
neutron star.
Neutron stars had been theorized in the
1930s, but were thought to be too faint to be
detected.
Neutron stars were hypothesized to exist, but
not really taken seriously.
It was just a oh, that's cute.
Maybe they're out there, but probably not.
The signal Bell detected seemed like
something from science fiction.
No one had ever seen this in astronomy
before, and some people even speculated that
it was an alien signal.
She even called them LGM objects little green
men.
But then Bell found a second signal.
Little green men went back to being fiction
and pulsars became science fact.
The discovery of pulsars came out of the
blue.
Nobody was expecting this.
So it was an amazing breakthrough, really
important.
Pulsars pulse because they're born to spin.
They burst into life as their parents star
collapses during a supernova.
Any object at all that is undergoing any sort
of compression event.
If it has any initial angular momentum at
all, it will eventually end up spinning.
As the star shrinks, it spins faster and
faster.
They spin so quickly because the earth sized
core of a massive star collapsed to something
as small as a city.
So because the size of the object became so
much smaller, the rate of spin had to
increase by a tremendous amount.